i don't think that for me like
taking a bow out of my hair like it's
not a new thing i have to take it out
every day you know what i mean
okay i don't know i don't know okay
brace for impact it's coming out all
right
jojo how are you how have you been doing
in
the getting excited for the holidays
while in a pandemic
times you know it's hold on mom i'm on
this
are you calling me right now
you're calling me right now
nailing it like that was amazing like
you know i'm on this zoom right now what
are you doing
that was the most mom thing ever mom i'm
on the zoom i'm in the next room and
you're calling me
mom i am on i'm doing an interview right
now um you know
we we are the type that are like
november 1st it is time to put up the
christmas tree
and i totally get why people don't do
that and i also because i do that i
totally get why people do do that
but now that we're past december 1st i
love the people that are like yeah
i finally get to put up my christmas
tree like i've been here for a month
like welcome to the party
and you have jojo's rock and christmas
how did you decide on these songs so we
did runner and rudolph
two years ago uh and then i just you
know i picked my favorite christmas
songs and
one of them obviously santa claus is
going to town and the other one is where
are you christmas
and if you'll cover yeah yeah
why can't i find you
why have you gone away
and everyone at first was like where are
you christmas
that's a lot of singing and that's a
very hard time to sing and i was like i
know
and i was like abby taught me back in
the day on dance songs you got to
be able to put your heart on the platter
and be ready for somebody to stab it and
with this song i was like we're gonna
we're gonna push myself and it might not
be the best version of worry christmas
ever my voice might not sound like
who's the girl that sings at faith hill
i was like i'm not even trying to sound
like faith hill
i know i'm not spleen beyond i know i'm
not kelly clarkson but i'm jojo
and you know i got the six-year-olds
that love it and that's
all that matters i love you you know
that brand girl you know
absolutely okay i'm gonna fire off some
holiday
just some numbers questions for you all
right one
how many holiday bows do you own
someone's going to kill me for not
knowing this answer
i'll go with like
97. 97.
i thought you'd give me like i don't
know exactly uh 28
97. yeah cause there's a lot cause you
gotta think
pretty much everyone gets an exclusive
bow for the holiday so like walmart
target amazon everyone gets like their
bow
but then there's a whole bunch of just
other bows and then i have custom bows
there's a lot you know i i hate myself
for this but i actually don't know how
you store
all your bows do you have a full bow
closet do you have drawers are they
organized and categorized so i'm
redoing my closet right now and there
has to be something really cool for my
bows in it though does
right now they're just shoved in a
drawer which i hate because my whole
life they've been on my wall but right
now they're just in a drawer
and i really like it yeah i need they
need like
to be like encrusted and gold somehow in
the closet like they need something good
cryogenically frozen in there something
to really preserve
i mean your fans know and love seeing
this personality of yours
but when the cameras aren't rolling
because you know you you film so much
and you do so much
do you have to like take it down a
little just to relax do you have to shut
down a bit to preserve energy
honestly no like i i am
the only the only like real difference
in like how everyone in the world sees
me and how like my best best best
friends see me
is i don't want to use the word shy but
like
i'm really more of like an introvert and
like i have just like
my little group of people and like i
don't like meeting new people like is
scary to me or like
especially teenagers like trying to meet
other teenagers i'm just like i'm good
i'm good i got my friends and that's
that's great for me i'll i'll keep them
around and call it good
but i mean i love like meeting fans i
love that like that is what i love
when little kids come up to me when
teenagers come up to me when grandmas
and grandpas come up to me like
i love that that's my favorite thing
ever do you think you
i mean of course you have this
incredible level of fame do you think
if you hadn't gotten that you would
still kind of be that
introvert with that small group of
friends it's interesting for me to hear
you say it's hard for you to meet
teenagers and get make friends with
teenagers
totally i think now with teenagers i'm a
little different because now
teenagers like me versus pre-quarantine
actually like before i kind of went to
tick-tock and like
really show the teenagers who i am they
all hated me
and hated my guts and you know the whole
like giant toddler the whole you're five
years old the whole receding hairline
like
that whole thing was a thing but now i
mean it's it's not really anymore like i
think
when i was little i was really really
like
loved school and i loved that land and i
still do but now
um i've graduated but like when i was
like in school
i loved that and i like wanted to be a
surgeon i either wanted to be a surgeon
or a pop star
and going going more one of the two ways
now
so i think if i wasn't doing this i feel
like i'd already be in college like i
feel like i'd just be so
like wow the smartest human in the whole
wide world that that's all i would be
focused on
do you ever think that one day down the
road you might
just totally pivot and then go to a
different type of career and if so what
would it be
i think one day i can make my surgeon
dreams come true and be on one episode
of grey's anatomy just one episode just
one i'll take one
um i love grey's anatomy it's it's i
mean it's my favorite show ever
the world knows that but no i think i
i realized even though i wanted to do
that too when i was little
i realized now that i was put on this
earth for one reason
and that i mean one main reason and that
main reason
is to perform and to make other people
happy i can't even explain like
the sense of like this is what i'm
supposed to be doing when i'm performing
it's like the most
perfect feeling like this is exactly
right just feels right
and nothing else makes me feel that
except for when i'm on stage
well i love hearing that you feel like
you've gotten to a better place with the
fellow teenagers and all that has it
kind of i i don't mean to see like
it bothered you before but has it helped
with your sense of self and confidence
to be in a better place with all that
and maybe not feel like you're getting
so much criticism you know i think
it's almost like a lot of people
rise to fame really fast and
for me it's kind of been like the right
pace i started when i was nine on my
first tv show
and that was i've always mainly been in
reality you know that was abby's
ultimate dance competition and then
dance moms and so
the criticism and the haters like have
always been there
and kalani actually said it best because
she
she was getting a lot of hate for her
views on the world and
she was like people are now hating on me
for my beliefs like this is the funniest
thing ever she's like i
this doesn't affect me at all she's like
normally they hate about
my body my personality my height my this
my that what i said if i'm this if i'm
not just like another any of my beliefs
like that's
nothing i know you've done stuff with
the kardashians before
of all the kind of fellow famous people
who you've met
who have you maybe connected with the
most on some of that stuff like been
able to talk through
those experiences with them or maybe
gotten great advice from
honestly the person that i've kind of
felt the most
like she gets it is with paris hilton
she because we both like are not
like she was like because she also was
like i don't know how to explain
it to people and i was like it's so good
because i know exactly what you're
saying because
i don't either it's not we're not a
character
but when we have just another side
and she was she was like that's
literally exactly it and i'm like but
that's not even the right way to explain
it so we're both trying to figure out
the right footage to explain it um
i also have a really good connection uh
with meghan trainor she's a sweetheart
kim is a sweetheart i mean everybody is
just so nice like once you really get to
meet people
they're so nice and of course everyone's
gonna have their moments and like
everyone who's a girl is gonna have
their girl time and like
that's just we're human you know what i
mean but i
i totally see the paris hilton thing
because she's talked about that that she
leaned into what was working for her
what people loved this character of
herself
but then that meant she committed to
that and how could she ever like reveal
who she really was like
i don't know do you tell me more about
how you feel about that and if you feel
yourself ever
getting away from your character you
know it's weird because
i always like say my halloween costume
was the exact right example i had
50 of this girl wearing a braid and a
black hoodie and black pants and a
sneaker
and then i had a girl wearing a side
ponytail and glitter
and a sequiny jacket and a sequiny skirt
and secret shoes
and like i called all my friends and i
told my friends i was like which one's
the alter ego and they were like
literally like it's the weirdest thing
we
the like the middle like it's the
weirdest thing
and so i would never say that like
jojo's a character i mean
jojo is me and and that's like kind of
the coolest part of my life is i get to
do
whatever i want to do but at the same
time
you know i think as i grow up i think
i'll change
and i think everything will change while
i change if that makes sense
but yeah can only predict the future so
much
i love that you're leaning into that
because i think there's also something
that's of course a little scary about
that like the whole world's watching you
grow up and
absolutely it's almost like i've just
like okay this is when justin bieber
released lonely
i was like this song is really
interesting because in a way
like trust me i'm not lonely at all i
have my best friends i have my family
like i
love my people around me keep me like
they are the best people ever
and but when i heard that song i was
like it's interesting because
no one just fully gets it and that song
like i really was like wow like he put
that into words
in a different way than like i would say
in my life is
but he put that into words and i was
like that is brilliant because that's
exactly it
yeah of course he's talked about like
the pressures of you know
things like you you you start having
those teenager times when you might want
to act out or be rebellious or then
you're going to start drinking
do you think about what these next
couple years look like for you and how
you want to balance and manage like
kind of a big time of change in your
life as you like i'm an adult
i mean i am a nebraska girl i i have my
family around me who are good people and
i keep my friends around me who are good
people and
you know i i can't handle fake people i
it's funny i have a very specific friend
type and it's people who
don't give me anything i want you know
what i mean it's a very specific like
very like
it's not just like i'm i'm not friends
with just anybody you know like
my people just get it and it just works
and that's how i know they're my best
friends
uh but like my thing is is like even if
i was a normal teenager not in the
spotlight
living in nebraska fully nobody knows
who i am
i would never take a sip of alcohol i
would never
vape like a vape to me is the scariest
thing
ever i feel like that is like literally
i would do anything in the world before
i would do that i think that is this
wait are you gonna drink when you're 21
or you you never see yourself drinking
i mean listen i'm sure my 21st birthday
is gonna be a fun time i'm sure
like i'm sure everyone's 21st birthday
is gonna be a fun time
but you know that's not just it's just
not who i am like
the last day of being 20 i'm not gonna
like
like i've no i have no interest i always
had this joke when i was little that
where i wanted to go for my 21st
birthday was applebee's and chucky keys
like that that's my type when you turn
21 we'll pull up this clip and see if
you go there
oh absolutely i will because i for my
whole life this is the one thing that i
actually like my life that i have ever
wanted to try is they have this slushie
and it's like swirled with strawberry
stuff and
if they had a virgin drink of it i would
100 get it but they just don't and i
like don't even want it for the alcohol
i just want it because that slushy has
looked
so good since i've been four years so
i'm like i'm gonna try it
i did see that you uh recently when you
did that makeover with james charles
okay i want to do a video together so
bad where i give you a full
transformation
yes you literally responded and i quote
hey
sorry i can't do that which everybody
just loved it was interesting i think
you said it scared you because
you don't like any type of change what
is it about
change that scares you and do you see
yourself
like you know i'm sure people have asked
you this before but will you ever make a
change and retire the bow
what what is it about change change
scares me
i don't like new things no new things
it's a saying that i live by my
choreographer taught me that saying
richie he said no new things nobody does
new things you stick to what works
oh wow i don't think that for me like
taking a bow out of my hair like it's
not a new thing i had to take it out
every day you know what i mean
okay i don't know i don't think but okay
race for impact it's coming out i mean
well we've seen somebody like miley
cyrus she had the hannah montana days
and then she goes through all these
evolutions and could you see
yourself just evolving as an artist
trying different things eventually
i i do and i don't i think the biggest
difference with
me and with somebody like miley somebody
like like
i mean any child star who has gone from
network because that's kind of the box
that i got
in with being with nickelodeon
everyone's like oh you're a network kid
you're going to go crazy and then you're
going to be a big star that's how it
works
the difference is is i have gotten to be
myself this whole time
no one's been like you are going to wear
a bow you are going to dye your hair
blonde
you are going to do this it's like last
night i was actually on the phone with
one of my best friends and
she was like what color is your natural
hair and i was like it's brown and she
was like
we should just have it brown and i was
like no baby i got a brand
and she was like well do you have to
have it i was like no i want to have it
is the thing
and fair she's like i i love
it she she's she's great she loves me
for who i am and that's that's
the friends that i love well you did
have a recent change in your life i know
that
you and your boyfriend broke up
the bow is still on so everything's
still okay they're still okay we're
still good
um what happened there and are you
dating anybody new
or looking to no i am i'm single as a
pringle right now but mark and i did
break up we were together for
for three months uh and it was it was
great we had fun you know we drove
through taco bell i think 450 times
uh we we had some really fun nights we
never
actually had any like hard time we never
fought we never
we never were mad at each other it was
it was honestly a great time
he it just we had to work
he had to kind of do some things in his
life that
you know i wanted to be there for him
and but but he had to be there
250 for him and i
didn't want to take away from him being
able to be there for him and so i was
like listen like
we can be friends and i when i when i
ended the relationship i was like i
don't want to just
say let's be friends and then let's not
like let's let's be friends and let's
make it normal
i mean he deserves nothing but greatness
so
do you know what you're looking for in
another guy will you date again anytime
soon you know my manager actually asked
me the same question she said so now
what like are you gonna get to another
relationship and
actually everyone's asked me that and my
thing is is my life is
so figured out like i you know i don't
go to school like i don't have to study
for tests right now i don't
my career is so like boom this is what's
happening and i just have to keep
running forward on that track
and so for me on the relationship side
of things it's more just like a
fun thing and and you know if it comes
around
great and if it if it doesn't come
around also great like i have so much
that i'm doing right now
that it's like all right like if anyone
wants to join the party like i'm down
but if nobody wants to join the party
all right cool like you know
what kind of what kind of guy are you
into in a couple words
in a couple words
nice
cares about me
[Music]
and is there for me if you're thick and
thin
you know they like marriage obviously is
like richer for poor for better for
worse
for sick and for well whatever
i don't know but that also goes
even just in a relationship or just in a
friendship you know you're going to be
there for each other
20 24 7. and that that's what's most
important to me is just somebody who
genuinely really truly cares about me
by the way i saw that on your instagram
you said that you were feeling kind of
sick but you powered through you're
giving yourself a wonderful makeup
how are you are you feeling better i
am feeling better but i am technically
not better so i did end up getting
it uh the the big breaded the big
dreaded coven 19 it got it got through
my whole family but it was
you know we all luckily were very much
just
very not awful symptoms you know we all
obviously we had headaches we were tired
we had shortness of breath we had we had
we had all the things all my family
actually lost their taste and smell
uh but i'll have it back but i never did
well i'm sorry i'm glad to hear you guys
didn't have crazy symptoms
so you never lost your sense of taste
and smell you were tasting all the
christmas cookies
i was tasting everything yeah and my mom
actually is who lost it the worst and we
were all kind of like
what's it like i heard the smell that
when you lose your smell and it comes
back that everything starts to smell
like onions and i'm like oh
i feel like it's just the thing with
this is like everyone is different like
everyone
who gets this viruses it's going to
affect them differently
and in my family my brother ended up
getting it and then my dad got it and
then my mom got it and then i got it
last it was like very like we were all
like three days apart
and so we started quarantine when my
brother got it and at first i was like i
just want it because i know i'm going to
get it and now we're just prolonging
this
time that we have to to hide away
basically
right but you don't because what if you
get it and something happens like you
just
let the world do what the world does so
next year we're almost done with 2020.
what are you most looking forward to in
2021
most looking forward to for me is
d-r-e-a-m the tour
i am so excited to go back on tour it's
gonna be incredible
but aside from tour i'm shooting
two movies in 2021 amazing and
one tv show in 2021 can you tease
anything for me about these movies any
co-stars we would know
co-stars you would know no not yet um
i'm doing a
i can't talk about it yet no i'll get
murdered if i do but i can't talk about
bounce and i'm very excited about bounce
that's one of the movies that i'll be
shooting this year that's uh
with with will smith's company so i'm
really really really excited about that
uh paramount's also doing it which is
really fun it's gonna be
such a fun movie oh my gosh the script
is so good i can't wait oh it's so good